- So, guess what. I love
sitting on my couch.
(Kahlana laughs)
in my roomy pants and my thick socks
scouring the internet for treasures.
And that's why I'm excited
we teamed with Rue La La.
(audience applauds)
So, those not familiar with Rue La La,
it's an online store where you can get
high quality designer items
at like insane prices.
You're going to freak out.
Lots of people know about this already,
so get in the know.
So here to rock this segment with me
is my long-time friend,
Kahlana Barfield Brown.
- Hi, Drew. (laughs)
(audience applauds)
- By the way, Kahlana,
when I first knew you,
you were just Kahlana Barfield.
- I sure was. I got married. (laughs)
- Oh, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- And Kahlana, I think you
did something three weeks ago
that was pretty important?
- I did. I had whole baby. (laughs)
(audience applauds)
- Listen, even when the world
is in the state it's in,
a lot of us are doing our
online shopping at home.
- Yep.
- Kahlana's gonna help us run down
this week's hot items on Rue La La.
And guess what. We've
rebranded this. It's now
- [Drew And Kahlana] Drew La La!
(audience applauds)
- [Drew] So Kahlana, what do we got first?
- Okay, so fall's officially here
if you can't tell by the
way the weather is changing,
so it's time for us to start transitioning
to our cozier pieces,
so the first item I have
is just for that.
It's a cashmere sweater the brand Naadam
and I just love, feel how soft it is.
- I know, this is gorgeous.
- It's so soft and cozy.
This color is called avocado.
- It comes in seven different colors?
- Seven different colors,
and it normally goes for $264,
but today we're getting it
at 69 percent off for $79.99.
(bell rings)
- Real cashmere for $79.99?
(Kahlana laughs)
- All right, so what else have we got?
- Okay, I'm really excited
about this, Dior sunglasses.
Dior gets it right every season.
Just designing styles that work for,
whether you're edgy or sophisticated.
No matter what your face shape is,
we have four different styles.
These sunglasses normally
go for up to $480.
We're getting them at $99.99.
That's a discount up to 79 percent off.
(bell rings)
(Kahlana laughs)
- Hi, it's me. I'm from the future.
(audience and Kahlana laugh)
- All right, what's next, Kahlana?
- So, I am obsessing over these bags.
It's from Ampersand as Apostrophe.
So there are two tote bags.
Actually, this one is
a tote-backpack hybrid.
Oh, you got the sunglasses
goin' on right now.
(laughs)
- It's a thing I like to do.
- So this is a backpack and tote hybrid.
So it has the straps in the back
for your backpack or you can hold it
with the top handle as a tote.
And the one you have over
there is a sideways tote
and it's so roomy.
Inside, there is a pouch.
And I love it because you
can use the pouch inside
as a little wallet.
The quality of this leather is so amazing.
The sideways tote normally goes for $682.
We're getting it for $279.99.
That's a 58 percent discount.
(bell rings)
And the backpack normally goes for $495.
We're getting it for $179.99.
That's a 63 percent discount.
(bell rings)
- [Drew] And what's last?
- Yeah, so we have these
gorgeous layered necklaces
from Rachel Rhinehardt.
We're both wearing them.
- [Drew] Yeah.
- And I love them because they are really,
they're like personal jewelry.
So it doesn't look too
bulky. They're delicate.
You can layer them with
other pieces you have
or you can wear them alone
and it still looks cool and interesting.
- See, I love that 'cause I
always see that layered look
and I just think it looks
so cool and effortless
but I know there's like a
whole system that goes into it.
- Right, the key is they have to,
the chains have to be different lengths.
You know, you look for one
that's more like a choker
and the one that's a little bit longer
and this gives you that effect.
It's one necklace, but
it looks like it's two.
So the necklace normally goes for $200.
We're getting it at $79.99.
That's a 60 percent off discount.
(bell rings)
- Everybody's priority of
how they spend their money
should be fun, not judged, personal,
and who knows what people
are gonna gravitate towards.
- Right.
- And we're just here to
show the magic of Rue La La
and what an amazing price point
that you can get this very
luxe, designer stuff for.
- Right, and all the great options.
- Kahlana, would you please do
me the favor of standing up,
because I just need to comment
on your head to toe look.
I mean, you have a black
and white threaded skirt.
- Yes. (laughs)
- You have like icicle strappy like shoes.
- Yes.
- You have a tie belted
jacket. You are so cool.
- Thank you, Drew.
- I'm getting like advice and tips
on how to do this all from you.
Ladies and gentlemen, like
look at the authority,
Kahlana Barfield Brown, okay.
- Thank you, Drew.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kahlana] Of course.
- Until we meet again, dahling.
(Kahlana laughs)
This has been Drew La La.
And for all of you at home,
you can find these items
at the real
ruelala.com/thedrewbarrymoreshow
and remember these
deals are only available
while supplies last.